aquí tenemos tres rectángulos para los
cuales nos dan el alto y el ancho bueno
en realidad este como el alto y el ancho
es el mismo pues es un cuadrado pero
bueno son rectángulos a fin de cuentas y
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
determinar cuál es el área de cada uno
de ellos cuánto espacio ocupan en la
pantalla como ya vimos el área depende
de cuántas unidades cuadradas caben en
la figura y como aquí estamos manejando
las dimensiones en metros entonces vamos
a medir el área en metros cuadrados
déjame empezar con este rectángulo de
acá vamos a ir colocando unidades
cuadradas recuerda que esta unidad
cuadrada este metro cuadrado consiste de
un cuadrado de lados 1 metro por un
metro vale bueno entonces ahí va uno
tenemos otro 2 otro más
y otro más por acá 4
este sería 5 y finalmente tenemos uno
más por acá que sería el sexto entonces
caben seis cuadrados y por lo tanto el
área de esta figura lo voy a poner por
acá el área
área es de 1 2 3 4 5 6 metros cuadrados
metros metros cuadrados cuadrados cuadra
2 excelente ahora a lo mejor ya te diste
cuenta de algo hasta ahorita lo que
hemos hecho para contar cuántos
cuadrados caben es contar los realmente
contar 1 2 3 4 5 6 pero podemos darnos
cuenta de otra cosa en realidad estos 6
cuadrados los podemos ver como dos filas
de tres cuadrados cada una
déjame marcar las filas digamos con
color rojo para que se noten entonces
aquí abajo tendríamos una fila de tres
cuadrados y aquí arriba tendríamos otra
fila de tres cuadrados entonces otra
forma de poder calcular el área es decir
lo siguiente es decir bueno pues tenemos
este 3 y este 2 vamos a multiplicar los
porque a ver qué sucede si hago 3 3
por 2 3 por 2
bueno eso me está diciendo que tengo 3
cuadrados en cada una de las filas y que
tengo dos filas entonces esta es otra
forma perfectamente válida de calcular
el área podemos escribirlo así podemos
decir lo siguiente es bueno déjame
ponerle aquí que esto es igual es igual
a 6 entonces de ahí sale el 6 pero otra
forma de escribirlo es con unidades 3
metros multiplicado con 2 metros con 2
metros es igual es igual a 6 metros
cuadrados metros cuadrados cuadrado
vale y bueno en realidad esto no es una
casualidad si tiene todo el sentido del
mundo simplemente este 3 viene de que
hay 3 cuadrados en cada fila y este 2
viene de que hay dos filas va pero bueno
a lo mejor todavía no está
suficientemente convencido así que vamos
a ver que esta misma idea funciona en
estos otros ejemplos de aquí abajo
déjame bajar un poco para tener más
espacio entonces aquí tenemos otro otro
rectángulo si esto que estamos diciendo
aquí arriba funciona entonces para
calcular el área de este rectángulo
basta multiplicar dos metros dos metros
por estos cuatro metros de acá por
cuatro metros y hacer la multiplicación
directamente 2 por 4 es igual a 8 y es
igual a 8 y metros por metros es metros
cuadrados metros cuadrados
para todos vamos a verificarlo colocando
cuadrados unitarios sobre este
rectángulo ahí tenemos 1
4 si se ve que va a salir verdad 4
observa que en cada fila estoy poniendo
2 cuadrados
ese es el 5 este es el 6
y ya nada más me falta la última fila
con s son 7 y 1 + dan 8 sale entonces
justo lo que estamos haciendo es déjame
tomar déjame tomar el color blanco para
marcar lo siguiente justo lo que estamos
haciendo es grupitos de 2 sale filas de
dos en dos y las de dos en dos de dos en
dos y como son cuatro filas por eso
hacemos la multiplicación de dos por
cuatro o bien podemos pensarlo de otra
forma también podemos pensarlo como que
son dos columnas dos columnas con cuatro
cuadritos cada una entonces también
pudimos haber multiplicado cuatro por
dos en vez de dos por cuatro daría
exactamente lo mismo vale entonces en
este de aquí también funciona vamos
ahora este rectángulo bueno a este
cuadrado sale entonces la idea sería
tomar tres metros
tres metros y multiplicarlo por estos
otros tres metros de acá por tres metros
entonces si todo está funcionando bien y
todo está funcionando bien entonces
tendríamos que el área el área es de 99
metros metros cuadrados cuadrados sale
el 9 sale de 3 por 3 este 13 es que hay
4 perdón 3 cuadrados por fila y este 3
es de que hay tres filas vale y podemos
verificar lo deja mejor lugar aquí las
unidades ahí va una 2
7 nada más faltan 2 8 8 y 9 entonces
esto está fantástico sale tenemos tres
filas de tres cuadrados entonces eso nos
da otra forma de contar cuántos
cuadrados unitarios caben cuántos
cuadrados de un metro cuadrado en este
caso y entonces en los rectángulos el
área es igual al largo por el alto